when the pandemic hit companies either
blew up or they got destroyed companies
that benefited from people staying at
home like zoom google amazon and
facebook went to the moon meanwhile
restaurants airlines cruise lines and
hotels went into the abyss and many of
them even filed for bankruptcy one of
the biggest beneficiaries of the
movement towards stereotome products was
an exercise equipment company called
peloton almost overnight they became
iconic for making high-end exercise
bikes and treadmills and their stock
boomed almost 10x from the pandemic lows
but ever since the start of 2021 peloton
hasn't been doing so well they've had to
recall a couple of products face a few
pr nightmares slash the prices of their
products by hundreds of dollars watch
their products oversaturate secondhand
markets lose their ceo and burn more
money than ever before as you would
guess the stock market hasn't been very
kind to this lackluster performance and
the stock has sold off 86 from the peak
so here is the rise and fall of one of
the biggest fads in the fitness industry
taking a look back the story of peloton
circles back to a man named john foley
we don't know too much about jon's
background other than the fact that he
seems like a traditional businessman who
climbed a corporate ladder he got
prestigious degrees in engineering and
business from georgia tech and harvard
respectively and through decades of work
he was able to become the president of
e-commerce at barnes noble at this point
most people would probably just try to
work up to the c-suite work for another
10-20 years and then retire comfortably
but it looks like jon had an
entrepreneurial urge that he had never
tended to so in 2012 at age 40 john made
the fateful decision to quit his job and
give business a shot he didn't want to
do it alone though so he convinced a
bunch of executive friends to take the
plunge with him this included graham
stanton hisokushi tom cortese and yanni
feng and given all of their connections
and personal wealth itself it wasn't
difficult to raise money
just one month after starting the
company they were able to raise four
hundred thousand dollars and by the end
of their first year they were able to
raise another 3.5 million dollars since
then peloton has managed to raise over
one billion dollars from their private
markets but anyway with their first few
millions they started developing their
flagship product which is their exercise
bike the idea was to allow people to
enjoy a high-end cycling class from the
comfort of their homes
each bike comes with a massive screen
that's capable of live streaming
workouts from dozens of their personal
trainers the product wasn't anything
game changing per se but it provided a
unique twist on a classic product and
usually that's all you need
people often get stuck up on trying to
find the next big idea when the best
idea is actually just to noticeably
improve something that already exists
anyway peloton turned to kickstarter to
launch their first bike with the goal of
raising 250 000
they were only able to garner a total of
297 backers but given that each bike
cost over a thousand dollars they were
able to beat their goal and raise 307
thousand dollars peloton would turn
around and release their bikes to the
general public in 2014 and with that
peloton was in business
over the next few years peloton slowly
grew a core base of hardcore users
initially their products mainly appealed
to real biking enthusiasts who wanted a
solid alternative to biking outside or
attending a real cycling class but with
the time their demographic would shift
closer and closer to everyday people in
may of 2018 peloton would attempt to
expand their audience by targeting
enthusiast runners as well with the
launch of the peloton tread plus and the
tread plus carried an even more bougie
price on their bikes starting at 4 300
it should also be noted that if you want
access to all of palton's classes and
live streams you have to get their
all-access subscription which costs 39
per month or 468 per year itself for
those prices i'm pretty sure it would be
way cheaper to get a gym membership and
just attend cycling classes in person if
a gym membership costs 30 per month it
would take nearly 12 years to pay the 4
300 that it would cost to just get the
tread plus despite these crazy prices
for people who highly value the
livestream classes and the convenience
there was no better at home alternative
also with time their high price tag
started to become more of an advantage
than a hindrance similar to other
high-end brands like apple and louis
vuitton peloton's high prices gave them
exclusivity and turned their products
into status symbols
if you were able to spend thousands on
an exercise bike and hundreds on a
subscription every year you clearly had
money in my opinion if you don't know
what peloton means you probably
shouldn't be getting their bikes and
this is how it mostly was till 2020 but
once the pandemic hit a large portion of
white-collar workers decided that it was
a great idea to buy some high-end
equipment to start exercising on and
over the next few quarters peloton's
revenue numbers would hit new all-time
highs and they would even post a few
profitable quarters but while peloton
was doing better than ever before
financially they were concurrently
dealing with the slew of problems in the
background
one aspect that most youtubers are
extremely careful of is avoiding
copyrighted music
even just a couple of seconds of
copyrighted music can get an entire
video demonetized unfortunately it looks
like peloton didn't have any youtubers
on their design team because they filled
their workout videos with copyrighted
music and in march of 2019 the national
music publishers association would hit
peloton with a 150 million lawsuit
peloton instantly responded by removing
the copyrighted music from all of their
courses and even removing some courses
that depended on the music most peloton
users weren't exactly happy with this
given that copyrighted music is
generally way better than
non-copyrighted music but peloton's
customers weren't the only ones that
were unhappy in september of 2019 the
music association would double their
allegations on peloton claiming a total
of 300 million dollars peloton did end
up settling for an undisclosed amount
that was likely lower than 300 million
dollars but i doubt that this was a very
good experience for peloton shortly
after they would find themselves in yet
another controversy with a commercial
called a gift that gives back the plot
of the commercial is a husband buying
his wife a peloton bike and the wife
becoming a lot more fit and athletic
over the next year most people would
just dismiss the commercial as another
fitness ad and not think much about it
but a select group of people felt that
peloton was promoting body shaming and
that the plot of the commercial implied
their husband was dissatisfied with the
wise physical appearance honestly it's
just a traditional fitness commercial
but the like to dislike ratio shows how
divided people were on the advertisement
despite all these controversies peloton
sales continued to rise through the
start of the pandemic but this led to
its own issues
peloton couldn't keep up with the
massive influx of new orders and many
customers had waiting times that
stretched several months this led to
many customers reconsidering their
orders and cancelling them a few months
into the weight while these growing
pains were likely annoying to deal with
it soon became clear that peloton had
much more deep rooted problems
the truth is that a significant portion
of the people who went ahead and bought
a pellet on it didn't actually stick to
using the peloton the thing is most of
these guys weren't enthusiasts bikers or
runners they were actually the type of
people who got a gym membership as a new
year's resolution and then only used it
five times throughout the entire year
and buying a peloton was basically their
cobot resolution many of them likely
felt that by spending a significant
amount of money and having live training
classes they would be more compelled to
work out and while this may have worked
for a few months or even several months
as people began to return to their
normal lives their fitness lives also
returned to being non-existent most of
these guys kept their pelotons around
for a few more months but eventually
they decided to sell them on ebay and
craigslist leading to these sites being
flooded with peloton listings not only
did these listings drive buying traffic
away from pelton's official website but
it sent a pretty strong signal that
everyday people who bought a peloton
didn't really find it that valuable
this isn't to say that peloton doesn't
make great products because their bikes
and treadmills are truly top of the line
these buyers were simply not part of the
target demographic and as they left the
scene peloton's revenue started to
stagnate and decline as pelotons started
to fall out of favor amongst everyday
consumers people and companies start to
poke fun at peloton ryan reynolds for
example hired the actress that played
the wife in the peloton commercial to
star in a gin commercial called the gift
that doesn't give back similarly just a
few months ago hbo aired an episode in
which a character called mr big suffers
from a heart attack and dies after
riding a peloton peloton shares would
fall 11.3 percent the day after this
episode aired on tv clearly peloton was
suffering from a fleeting customer base
and a shifting public image but it
didn't take long for things to go from
bad to worse
the nail in the coffin for peloton came
in march of 2021 when a video was
released of a child being sucked into
the back of a peloton treadmill and
dying following this story we saw dozens
of reports suggesting that adults
children and pets were injured due to
peloton products
honestly i'm not sure why peloton
received so much heat when a lot of the
fault is shared by the users of their
products nevertheless pelton implemented
a slew of software-based safety features
within the next month but this wasn't
enough to appease all the criticism they
were receiving from the media and in may
of 2021 peloton would finally give in
and issue a recall for their tread and
tread plus treadmills which is valid
till november of 2022 and the peloton
has been losing hundreds of millions per
quarter ever since i suspect that a lot
of the returns are just people cashing
in on an impulse purchase as opposed to
people returning these treadmills due to
legitimate safety concerns i guess it
was just these customers lucky day given
all this negative pr and the
oversaturated secondhand market peloton
was forced to slash prices to continue
appealing to customers which has just
made it even harder to turn a profit as
losses continue to pile up peloton has
been forced to make harder and harder
decisions one of these decisions came in
early february when peloton went ahead
and reduced the workforce by 2800
employees this was around the same time
that jon foley resigned from the company
and was replaced by barry mccarthy so
far john has lost his position as the
yoa and his status as a billionaire the
only question left is will jon also lose
his company
looking forward while pelton is
definitely in a terrible position right
now i think it's unlikely that they'll
file for bankruptcy and completely shut
down despite all their ups and downs
peloton has been able to grow a strong
base of core users that wouldn't use
anything else and just maintaining this
customer base could be quite lucrative
for peloton given their high
subscription fees with that being said
though the next few quarters don't look
that great as it's unlikely that peloton
can really start to build up positive
momentum again until the recall period
is over even after the recall is over
it's unlikely that peloton will ever
enjoy the same amount of interest and
excitement that they enjoyed at the peak
of the pandemic but over several years
it's possible that they're able to build
up a large enough base of enthusiasts
that they're able to pull in more
revenue and profit than ever before but
we'll just have to wait and see do you
guys think pelton will rise from the
ashes or do you think it will become an
infamous fitness fad comment that down
below also drop a like if you think
pelotons are overpriced and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other
languages and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]